how do you make so much
[Music]
content but how do you make so
much I have 29 full-time employees on my
content team Gary V is the team that
actually builds all the content for
Gary's brand we are a team of about 35
individuals living all over the globe a
lot of people would call me S the intern
still I start as an intern on this team
I am Executive Vice President here at
Vayner now I lead the brand our goal is
to Showcase Gary's Life in the way where
people can see the behind the scenes and
also get value from all the
conversations he's having on a day today
we take 15 minutes to an hour of his day
and make that into his full content
strategy there's been a lot more things
that Gary has started doing and the time
that we had with him has kept constantly
decreasing so the goal from our side is
always to show him what we're up to get
his feedback get some insights at the
end of the day the main goal is to make
Gary most famous entrepreneur of this
generation let me just kick this off
first of all it's really great to be
with everybody first and foremost this
is probably the most challenging year
for my brand and my content probably
since 2013 I am fully operating vriends
and Vayner media in a real [__] way
but there are a lot of things looming V
friends obviously the live streaming
that has been very substantially
important for the brand you know I
always say with my content through the
years don't listen to what I'm saying
watch what I'm doing you know I'm
excited to go into this year I'm excited
to listen today I'm excited to
brainstorm with all of you and I'm
excited to figure out what will work for
us one word to describe the offset
thought provoking lots of content
coming some of the people who are really
OG here know that I'm still frustrated
that we don't use search Gary the way
like I dream it I know in those thousand
episodes of Wine Library TV I have crazy
comments of the building of Twitter
there's a website that has blown up over
the last 6 months on the internet called
Twitter I believe that the content that
sits on the internet from 2006 to 2016
is some of the most interesting stuff
for us to debate the biggest impact we
can have is not dwell consciously or
subconsciously that there's not new
video I definitely also have 18 seconds
to add one sentence to something I said
11 years ago that is historically
correct or an interesting insight to
where we are
now I think the actual future of social
media the way we all see it right now if
there's the next Tik Tok before we go to
a new form factor off phone I believe
the way that platform can beat Tik Tok
is being even more extreme than Tik Tok
literally someone like me getting 91
views a video or the next one getting 91
million why did Tik Tok win the upside
not the downside if everyone here knew
tomorrow they could post and it could
get 139 million views you would be more
incentivized to do it that's what Tik
Tok did it brought everyone in cuz
everyone had a shot at a time where
Instagram was at maturity and everyone's
like well [__] Gary V already has 8
million followers I have 17 I'm out one
word to describe the offset I prob have
to say like mind-blowing recharge
exciting inspir
[Music]
inspirational look I think what we're
going to leave here with that's clear I
think is massive I keep going back to
the way this meeting started cuz I'm
excited about it it's just incredibly
obvious that everything I've ever
believed is true creative is the
variable of success and we can hack but
then that makes us just like everybody
else who doesn't realize they can't hack
themselves to success like you have to
good all right thank you
team really good session with the team
really rethinking content making it
frictionless given how busy I am and uh
thought it was really productive 3 hours
so really happy good to do team Vibes
and it was intense and
focused